Oda has finally revealed zoro's father
if you didn't know and today we'll be
discussing his history powers and more
shocking details about his true identity
so make sure to stay tuned for that
chill parking within and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing one piece
videos like this one on the Channel I
want to keep them coming make this the
video you join the Knock by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications so you don't
miss future one piece videos and updates
you can help us reach our insane goal of
2 million subscribers here on YouTube
with one click of that virtual button
and I would be eternally grateful for
that and now without further Ado let's
jump into It spoilers and all so
although it may be weird for some people
Oda has revealed zoro's entire family
tree in an SBS rather than doing it in
the main story that's one of those
sections between the actual chapters in
a manga volume I know some people don't
like when Oda releases such important
information outside of the story but as
we'll see the SBS still leaves room for
some cool reveals in the main story of
the manga so let's briefly go over that
that s SPS before we really get into the
specifics and the crazy implications of
zoro's father and his powers so zoro's
Grandparents were roronoa pinzo and
shimoi furo who was the older sister of
shimoi ushimaru because of their similar
appearance the fact that ushimaru was
also a gifted swordsman the fact that
ushimaru was also the descendant of the
sword God and Zoro lookalike shimoi
ryuma many thought that ushimaru was
actually zoro's father but he was
actually his great uncle as this SPS
revealed we'll Circle back to the
significance of that reveal shortly
because it shattered a very popular
theory about zoro's father in the
community a theory so popular that I
think virtually everyone who talks about
one piece on YouTube covered it but back
to that in a bit for now we are told
that zoro's Grandpa roran NOA pin Zoro
was a swordsman from shimsky Village so
Zoro has swordsman on his grandma and
grandpa's sides which perhaps helps to
explain why he's so gifted himself so
back to the family tree and shimoi fuo
and roronoa Pen Zoro had a a child named
roronoa arashi he married a daughter of
thieving Bandits called terara together
they had roran NOA Zoro so there you go
that's his father and mother we're told
Mother Tara whose name means Earth died
of an illness meanwhile roro arashi at
least we're told here died in a battle
against Pirates his name arashi means
storm that's the info we got in the SPs
but we're going to go much further here
before that though let me bring up the
prevalent Zoro father theory that was
shattered by this SPS namely the theory
that zoro's father was ushimaru and that
ushimaru was Admiral greenbull many have
pointed out what they thought were clues
of this connection and once we get into
them you'll see that they are pretty
difficult to ignore for instance
ushimaru although Ura has revealed now
that he had blue hair he still wore a
robe with a green Bol on it I mean you
got to admit in and of itself that is a
big coincidence and the points go on
fujitora and by extension aramaki as a
Duo appear to come from wano yes fujit
to dresses in a more traditionally iano
style but many have pointed out the
first one I know of being Mr morg and is
now over 2-year-old video called proof
greenbull is zoro's father that the two
are written as a duo with history and
given that these powerhouses came from
outside the Marine system unlike past
Admirals it's likely that they would
have come from wano a place outside of
world government control and the place
that even sakazuki didn't want to mess
with because of the power of their
Samurai which she called an unknown
military force in wano a fear like that
definitely made sense if you know two
Admiral level characters came from the
place so the SPs revealed that ushimaru
is clearly not zoro's father and since
that Discovery was made I personally
haven't seen anyone else talking about
greenbull still being zoro's father and
since Oda told us that arashi died in a
battle against Pirates that also
probably led to people dropping the
green boro's father Theory however is
there more to meets the eye here and is
it too soon to give up hope on the
greenbull is zoro's Father theory yes
ushimaru is not zoro's father and yes
greenbull is probably not ushimaru but
that's exactly why greenbull still can
be zoro's dad despite the fact that now
we know ushimaru can't be since he's
zoro's great uncle so how can we take
oda's SPS information into account and
still argue that greenbull is zoro's
Father well for starters we accept that
roran NOA arashi died but in a wesle in
The Princess Bride kind of way where he
quote unquote died only to change his
identity and become the dread Pirates
Roberts and honestly we don't even have
to look outside of one piece for a
precedent for this think about how the
pirate Kudo faked his death and took on
a new identity or how the thought to be
dead Sabo lost his memories so he forgot
about Luffy if Oda brought zoro's father
a supposedly Dead character back it
definitely wouldn't be the first time
and he'd probably get even less backlash
than usual because it was in an SPS that
it was revealed not in the actual main
story and in this case it would make a
lot of sense just think about how he
writes other characters and their
fathers think about it sanji's Dad bad
guy but special Usopp dad special
Luffy's dad very special and all of them
alive Oda never shied away from giving
his most important characters important
parents not to mention living parents
that still have agency in the world of
one piece even for Shanks it's becoming
more and more apparent that St figland
Garling is shank's relative if not
straight up his father then think of Ace
and Roger and the list just goes on in
such a series it's likely that zoro's
father would also be a big deal and even
come back to play in the story like all
these other fathers considering how
important and strong Zoro is I can't
imagine arashi's story being just a
footnote in an SPS saying he died in a
battle against Pirates it's just not the
way Oda does things especially for his
most hyped characters and keep in mind
just like Zoro arashi was a descendant
of the sword God Ruma ushimaru was his
uncle and his dad was also a swordsman
so it's very unlikely he would go down
so easily as this SPS makes it appear so
regardless if he got amnesia like Sabo
or not if he's a bad guy dad like Vince
smoke judge or not we're arguing here
how arashi might have died only to take
on a new identity that of aramaki and he
even got to keep the first three letters
of his name one of the meanings of the
word aramaki is to cover and it could
well be that he's covering up his true
identity that of arashi now let's look
at all the clues that greenbull is
zoro's father and there are a lot
including new ones and even ones as
we're going to get into in the SPs
itself but we don't have to discard the
old clues either for instance was the
son of the sister of the guy who wore
green Bulls on his robe in other words
we don't have to abandon that huge
coincidence the green Bulls could be a
family thing passed on from one
generation to the next and so the fact
that the Admirals called greenbull could
still point to it being zoro's father
then there's the fact that unlike
ushimaru it was revealed in the anime
that green bull does have green hair
again there are a lot of other
characters with green hair and they
obviously aren't related to Zoro so I'm
not saying aha they both have green hair
so they have to be related however taken
together along with everything else that
I've mentioned and I'm going to mention
it just makes for a stronger case that
greenbull is zoro's Father we mentioned
why many in the community feel that
greenbull is originally from wano which
would make sense for zoro's father as
well then there's green Bull's Powers if
you'll recall arashi's wife was called
Tera which means Earth in several
languages since green Bull's Woods Woods
fruit powers make him a Forest human
which is heavily related to the idea of
terara and the Earth it seems to be
another nod from Oda as to his true
identity then there's just the countless
parallels between Zoro and greenbull as
we know like Zoro arashi had Swordsmen
on both sides of his family so chances
are he was a gifted swordsman in his own
right well although we haven't seen him
use it yet greenbull has a shirasaya
like Katana on his hip it must be said
greenbull after all the hype was
seemingly pretty underwhelming at wano
it at least when we consider what
happened after he made quick work of the
Beast Pirates he seemed to have trouble
with the red scabrid Momo and Yamato and
then ran away when Shanks told him to
keep in mind this dude has a three Crown
Bounty AKA a bounty of three billion
like the other Admirals like GARP and
even like Luffy so the most obvious
explanation for why he was underwhelming
against the scabbards Momo and Yamato is
probably because he didn't get serious
before Shanks interrupted him and in my
view the sword is probably the proof of
that going full out he probably uses his
sword and if he is a
then he's likely a beast with that sword
and by the way that Katana itself is
just another nod to his wano Origins
many have also mentioned the parallel to
Zoro and green Bull's introductions Zoro
was introduced as someone who broke his
fast because a girl gave him food while
greenbull is introduced as someone who
hasn't eaten in 3 years but would eat if
a girl were to feed him and this is one
of my personal favorite touches because
it's hilarious Zoro has been called a
moss head by Sanji how many times while
greenbull pretty much has a quite
literal Moss BOS head when he transforms
into his giant forest human form I mean
he clearly deserves the title way more
than Zoro and how can you not think of
all sanji's insults when you see him in
his Forest human form now I know if
you're a one piece fan I don't need to
tell you about zoro's love of booze so
I'll just point out that green bull
loves it too when he was soloing the
remnants of the Beast Pirates he
immediately asks if they can bring him
some booze he literally soaks the stuff
up using his roots then there's the fact
that Zoro has a terrible sense of
direction and when greenbull was asked
where he was by sakazuki he answered in
the air which to me is a pretty Zoro
response and we also saw that in zoro's
family tree there's a bunch of names
there associated with gambling terms we
also seen Zoro gamble multiple times
including the time he almost got his arm
cut off by a supposedly cursed sword and
to me greenbull definitely seems like a
gambler as well just think about it
alone against sakazuki orders he went to
wano to kill Luffy where the remnants of
the Beast Pirates and the people that
beat them and more people are yeah when
shank showed up he's like all right I'm
going to peace out but still just going
alone against his superior's orders in
such a environment filled with such
strong characters it's a very big gamble
indeed and yet another parallel between
him and Zoro like Zoro greenbull Beyond
hair color is associated with the color
green obviously which groups these two
together even more I mean just think
about it you can't think of either one
of them without thinking of the color
green there's also a potentially big
connection I can only make after the SPs
was revealed un likee the other Admirals
green will has a tattoo on his body that
says double unal living and yes I'm
censoring that for YouTube anyways this
is a reference to a popular Japanese
film and suggests a depressing past with
a woman would that detail not fit
perfectly with what Oda revealed in his
SPS about terara tragically dying of
illness and then arashi supposedly dying
in a battle with pirates what I really
love about this detail is in my view it
really strengthens the argument that
greenbull could be zoro's father while
for most people the SPs probably
destroyed the theory and their minds
because it proved ushimaru wasn't zoro's
dad but as I've been saying ushimaru
doesn't have to be greenbull for this
Theory to work thus ushimaru being
zoro's great uncle and greenbull being
arashi AKA zoro's dad can both be true I
won't get too much into green Bull's
seeming love of celestial dragons and
his respect for sakazuki as he
deliberately ignores his orders since
there is just so much we don't know a
lot of stuff about his character what he
says and what he does comes off as a
contradiction for instance he seems to
be really close to fujitora on good
terms with him one second and yet his
ideology seems cooler than sakazuki is
the other second while fujitora seems to
be a really good guy with two characters
like that really get along I don't think
so but for this video I don't think it's
really necessary to get into the truth
behind what adamaki is covering up
whether it's some kind of purposeful
cover or Amnesia or falling to the dark
side because of the sorrow of losing his
wife my point was only to prove that
there are many clues that the forest
human green bull could actually be
zoro's father arashi to prove this it
doesn't matter if turns out to be a good
or bad guy because we saw with Sanji
just because you're a main character's
parent doesn't mean you're automatically
a good guy but let me know if you're
convinced or at least agree with me that
there is a strong case for zoro's father
actually being Admiral greenbull even
after that SPS was revealed and if you
did enjoy this video about zoro's father
and his powers then you won't want to
miss my video about shank's true
identity and Powers finally being
revealed link to that is on screen right
now like And subscribe to help us reach
our dream of 2 million subscribers here
on YouTube and I'll see you in the next
one